and I hate much it's like my least
favorite thing to do we usually don't
talk about it unless we need to I know
it's something need to do but I don't
necessarily have the greatest feeling
about it
me and my husband are really trying to
figure out what works for us right now
every dollar is a budget tool it's been
called numerous things budget software
it's been called an app
we do have an iPhone app but technically
it's a budget tool the company has had
software budget software of some kind
going back to the late 90s fast forward
to about 2003 2004 we developed a tool
called gazelle budget as part of the my
Total Money Makeover website and we
started looking to what people were
really using and we found out oh my gosh
it's it's like all about the budget
we surveyed thousands of thousands of
people we've talked with hundreds and
hundreds of people just to watch people
do a budget one person's in control of
the computer the other one is sitting
there looking and agreeing and tending
to the dog and tending to the kids and
so that person had no investment in
their budget there are people out there
who want to have control of their money
but they don't exactly know how to
people are either spending carelessly
and not really knowing where their money
is going or they're dealing with
complicated systems where budgeting is
just a drag so to speak
money touches everybody's lives
everybody has some kind of either
amazing experience with money or bad
experience with money whatever your goal
is in some regard it's usually gonna
come back to money it seems like
everybody has looked at budgeting as
something that's impossible to do and so
the Nerds and the free spirits are two
different camps and the Nerds have kind
of taken over the budgeting world and
said we're the only ones that know how
to do it which is just not true and
there's nothing out there that makes
budgeting easy so we wanted a
free-spirit personality to be able to
sit down into a budget in ten minutes
and feel confident we had come up with
all of these you know convoluted systems
to make our way work of doing it and we
had to say how do we actually give every
dollar a name how does Dave teach people
to do it and how do we put that in
software that follows those rules but
it's still flexible enough to meet
people's needs
we have developers we've got people that
do user experience
Quality Assurance testing I mean it
takes a lot of people to deliver Dave
Ramsey's budget software to the
marketplace because we know the instant
that we start talking about this there
are going to be so many people coming to
this and we have to deliver I get to
talk with all the customers and learn
their stories how they think how they
act what they do are they gonna respond
well to emails should we have more
content available for them on social we
just have to think about what's gonna be
most valuable to them what are we gonna
actually design for how the people are
gonna use it that are going to use it so
you cut and they all that down and then
you start to design for it and you start
to craft what the product might look
like well debate
you say this is the way it's gonna work
this is the way it's gonna work so we
take them all out there and test them
we're bringing back find out none of
them are gonna work at all yet those
people on our team have unique stories
maybe they're they're working their way
through the baby steps or maybe they
have family anniversary we're on Dave's
plan and being able to see people go
from being enslaved to money to actually
winning with it is a huge win for people
who work here I've watched a lot of
people hurt with finances and it's all
about the foundation of a budget we came
up with three words that we landed on we
said this has to feel simple it has to
be functional you can't beat things
working in the background and you don't
understand it it has to be when you look
at it you intuitively know and then
third is it has to feel happy in a way
that was fun that where you could in 30
seconds a day unless you could actually
keep up with your budget users are
already struggling with their finances
the last thing they need to struggle
with is the tools it's the one that is
truly budgeting software everything else
is accounting software you push a button
you're in create a sample budget for you
and then you just get started it just
rolls one month to the next it's so easy
that people will be able to take control
their money like never before both
parties in the marriage can sit down and
look and see that's what I spent and it
goes there we overspent
or they dragged down like yes they're
empowered and that's fun my long-term
expectation for every dollar is that it
redefines how people think about
budgeting and because it's free there's
no friction they just go sign up and
they do it money is something that is a
human thing and we want to have that
human elevator these people are trusting
us with their budgets and we need to be
able to deliver them the best experience
that we can I was a part of the starting
of that thing called every dollar the
product we're delivering to the market
today is amazing but I want them to
really think about what it can become
over time this is the beginning
you